so looking ahead to to some exciting
things both of you have going on
vera taking on eleanor bishop in the
hawkeye series
how excited are you yes ma'am haley
kills it in the role yes
yes um he trains a new successor hawkeye
trains a new successor
and uh yeah and so kate bishop's coming
up and i play her mama
and it's just yeah i had a blast i had a
blast it's to be
pretty special i think yeah i've loved
seeing those set photos so far like
everything just looks amazing so i i
can't imagine how you're feeling
and then patrick for you it's funny we
talked for annabelle creation and i was
like oh are you coming back for aquaman
too and you're like nice
i you're not getting anything out of me
but now
now i feel like you can say something so
aquaman two co-written by jason momoa
himself
what are we in store for and how does it
compare to its predecessor
yeah well i think like with anything
with james when he comes back for uh
for a sequel he uh it's it it becomes
bigger and
better and broader and more funny more
action
more character work so um
yeah i've uh it's cool it's really fun
it's super fun we've we've i've been in
training now for about
it's my eighth week training so and then
i go and um
yeah in a couple months we start well
they start yeah about a month and a half
a month or so they start
i loved this movie i thought it was
creepy a beautiful love story
funny at times i love the detective
aspect of things
what were your initial thoughts about
the story given that it does kind of
move away from the haunted house concept
that we've seen before
yeah i was excited you know we always
now that we've done a handful of them uh
because we know we'll all be in the same
room at least when we're shooting
one so usually towards the end of that
if we feel like it's going really good
there's usually a
hey you got any ideas for the next one
you think there'll be another one so
i remember when we first heard about
this case i think we're shooting the
second one right here
i think so yeah um so then you go and
you google it you find out the
information and
and then you see oh wow the fact that
this was a real homicide and so
everything that comes in that the
responsibility that comes with that and
the real
you know real stakes victims here so
that that's something that
that we knew was going to take a much
different path and also open it up
because then it's not just
a family and they're hearsay even
throughout their own community
now it's an actual homicide how this
plays out the first case in history in
american history of using it as an alibi
in court so now we're double that we're
doubling down in court saying this is
the work of the devil and what what that
means what that means working with the
police department lorraine's clairvoyant
so
all of a sudden it just becomes a much
broader uh broader story which was
exciting because we don't want to come
back and just do the same thing
i mean the the the fact that it was
based on a true story i'm a big like
true crime fan i listen to podcast all
the time
immediately i was like in a wikipedia
wormhole right after watching this movie
being like oh my god this really
happened this is insane i
couldn't really find anything on like
where arnie and debbie are now did you
guys like
they're still around like did you guys
like talk to them or anything were they
involved with this movie at all
you know they were on set i keep
yeah i know but i have nothing much to
tell you because i usually
keep my distance and i can't even give
you a good reason why
i just do yeah they had come to they
were interviewed on set
they were there for a day yeah
and that's also been part of each each
film that we've done the family that
were we're doing the story about
they they'll come for a day or two and
you know
see the set and see what's going on and
see where their
life story ends and then becomes
dramatized and
you know um i believe i believe rory
probably talked to him i know actually
sadly we just lost
debbie debbie just passed away quite
recently like like
very recently the past few months so
yeah that was
that was certainly very sad but uh i
believe that
they um the two people playing them were
able to
talk with them but yeah we did sort of
st stay
away
no it's interesting because i was trying
to find stuff and it was like half the
family is like really against
the like demonic thing and then the
other half is like very supportive of it
so i was just
very fascinated about that whole thing
yeah no it's always there
in the family yeah so this is both of
your i think the sixth
film that you've done in part as part of
this franchise
and i'm sure you get asked this a lot
but because it i mean this is probably
my
favorite conjuring movie so far like i
really really liked it
so do you guys see more films in the
future do you see yourselves
keeping going with this uh what would
you like to see next i hope so
ash i hope so i i just give me another
outfit i would love to do it
again and again but at least one more i
think there's room for one
i think like for me watching it i'm like
oh there's so many paths we can go now
like i loved watching you guys
kind of be like detectives this time
around yeah
no that was a very cool aspect of it
because that was something that
um that i remember
even separately from the movie i it's a
long story but i i my my parents became
friends with someone that
that this that was their job as a
clairvoyant for this police department
for like
30 years or something totally wow then
you really realize
that many police departments have that
it's just sort of
low-key you know on the dl because a lot
of people just don't believe
it they don't believe it until it helps
you know um and then
then then you can't argue it um so that
was something with this story that i
thought
really did open the world up and make it
much more
real because we always just like to put
them in
in just strange situations just because
it's it's fun it's fun playing people
that with
little matching outfits and things um so
we always like to put them in the
strangest situation possible so it was
like let's put them in england what's
what are they like in england they have
any english cases yes they did okay
you know and this was put them in the
real world put them with police who are
going to be skeptics and
so now we're just trying to figure out
what other stories we can tell with them
so uh just to wrap it up here it's made
clear in this movie i i love the
the the love story between ed and
lorraine in this franchise and i feel
like it's the glue of the whole thing
and they make it clear in this movie
that
it was love at first sight for them i'm
curious what your first
impressions were of each other oh
um i worked very very closely with his
wife
on a project that i directed and um
absolutely adore his wife and
you know and i think was
that the first time we met did we first
meet there we got upstate new york we
met
we went outside of this situation the
reason why
when when at first i heard that you that
they had
gone out to you and i thought oh okay
okay i see it now
if if patrick says yes then then i see
it i see the film
right uh but i actually met you upstate
new york it wasn't
was on this we had already known each
other um
a bit the same way i remember talking to
james when they were we were putting it
together
and um yes and he had said they were
out of here or going out to veer
whatever it was i forget where we were
in the process but
it was the same thing where i thought oh
okay if if if that's the direction we're
going then it just
it just does up the ante it just really
showed their
um their their their dedication and
wanting to
be in this for the long haul and really
get the best people possible for it
myself excluded it was strange for me i
was because i knew your wife and i was
so affectionate with your wife and i was
so close
to your wife and it yeah actually i
don't even know what to say
if you meet someone if you meet someone
on a scale of like one to ten and
usually
you meet them on the first day and
you're like at a one like hello nice to
meet you
and you hope that at least by the end of
that experience you're like a six or
seven and i feel like
because of our shared history of my wife
um because also my wife is polish
and vera's got some ukrainian roots so
there's an eastern european thing that i
was almost like
all right i got you i know how to do
this you know that there was a lot of
these common bonds
i i live in jersey shelves from jersey
so there was a lot of just sort of
circling each other that i felt like
when we showed up to actually work
we were already probably at like a four
or five even without having
tons of conversations together it was
just a tremendous amount of
the way i think we viewed life and we
viewed family that we viewed our spouses
and then we viewed work and when you
come in uh
knowing that each that you've got a
tremendous amount of respect
and uh and a kernel of trust and
and humor you can you can you can jump
right in